mary-kate and Ashley Olsen enjoy a rare  night out with her sister Elizabeth  Tuesday night was a special occasion for  the three ladies they stepped out to  celebrate the launch of Mary Kate Nash  Lee's flagship la boutique Elizabeth and  James Elizabeth is an actress and also  half of the inspiration behind the name  of the twins label mary-kate looks chic  is always wearing a long black coat and  a gray and black slip dress underneath  she balanced the monochrome look with a  red crocodile bag and colorful bracelets  ashley looked distinctive with her  platinum blonde hair and also rocked a  long coat but hers was a beautiful  winter white she paired her look with  red crocodile pumps that matched Mary  Kate's pert 27 year old Elizabeth stood  in the middle in a more casual ensemble  the actress wore rolled up jeans a black  t-shirt with a long white jacket and  heels